el canciller colombiano Álvaro Leiva
dijo que espera que esta conferencia
internacional siente las bases para un
acuerdo que lleve a elecciones libres en
Venezuela qué tan factible Es que esto
ocurra teniendo en cuenta el panorama de
ese país y que por ejemplo solo una
parte de la oposición era la que
dialogaba con el gobierno de maduro
bueno el panorama es ciertamente difícil
pero él solo hecho de que haya
conversaciones para tratar de destrabar
el hecho de las sanciones que tanto daño
han producido a la comunidad venezolana
a la ciudadanía común y no al gobierno
Porque al fin y al cabo el venezolano
común es el que sufre los embates de la
de la escasez de Electricidad de la
imposibilidad de invertir en el sector
eléctrico o en el hidrológico entre
otros sectores entonces lleva como
consecuencia que las sanciones afectan
fundamentalmente a la ciudadanía común y
no al gobierno cualquier negociación que
apunte a destrabar estas sanciones y
auspicie mecanismos según los cuales
pueda haber más libertad más democracia
y nos aproximemos a unas elecciones cada
vez con mejores condiciones Siempre será
bienvenido además también es notorio el
hecho de que los Estados Unidos van a
participar en esa conferencia lo cual le
da una amplitud mayor también en los
Estados Unidos le conviene que tanto en
Colombia como en Venezuela haya paz
estos mecanismos de entendimiento van a
producir Dios quiera unos avances en el
caso venezolano y Dios quiera que
también algunos avances en Colombia
porque la paz de Colombia y la paz de
Venezuela convienen a ambos países pero
también a los Estados Unidos que siendo
socios hemisféricos deberían estar
interesados en que Venezuela y Colombia
marchen juntos en acuerdo con las
políticas norteamericanas y no lanzarlos
en brazos de China y de Rusia que es el
peligro más latente que tenemos hoy por
hoy Bueno y realmente es viable un
levantamiento de las sanciones que
países como Estados Unidos le han
impuesto a Venezuela porque pasos
concretos tendría que dar el gobierno
venezolano para que eso ocurra bueno las
garantías que el gobierno americano está
pidiendo como elecciones libres la
libertad de los presos políticos a lo
mejor no las conceden todas Pero el solo
hecho de que se Avanza en esa materia es
un es un paso significativo el hecho de
que el cne el Consejo Nacional electoral
venezolano ofrezca condiciones para la
participación de todos va a ayudar a que
haya un proceso electoral mucho más
abierto mucho más flexible y
garantista digamos de la participación
de todos
Hay que incorporar a esas discusiones a
todos los factores de oposición no solo
los que estuvieron representados en
México que por cierto pertenecen a los
partidos que el gobierno venezolano ha
inhabilitado o judicializado debería
participar toda la oposición y todos los
factores independientes que hacen vida
política en Venezuela ese sector de la
oposición no representa a toda la
oposición eso es más que Ob en el caso
venezolano y habría que propender a
abrir las puertas para la participación
de todos yo creo que le conviene a todos
que se acaben las sanciones porque estas
además no han servido para nada no
sirvieron en Corea del Norte que tiene
71 años de gobiernos con la misma
familia tres miembros de una misma
Dinastía sesenta y cuatro años en Cuba y
las sanciones no han acabado con las
dictadura cubana las sanciones en sí
mismas no sirven lo que sirve es la
negociación tampoco han servido las
negociaciones en el caso de Rusia que
ahora es más rica y más poderosa y
además abrazada con china en un grave
error de política exterior que han
cometido Europa y los Estados Unidos ese
ese acercamiento de Venezuela y Colombia
con los Estados Unidos es básico para la
comprensión de la política mundial
actual lanzar a Venezuela a Brasil que
es una economía muy poderosa de las más
grandes del mundo y que pertenece a los
bricks que cada vez se hacen más
poderosos y ricos no es conveniente para
América no es conveniente para el
hemisferio occidental Estados Unidos
tiene que propender a una relación Más
directa con Colombia con Venezuela entre
otros pero sobre todo
arrancárselo de los brazos a China y a
Rusia